[Música]
en medio de la atención que vive en
rusia y ucrania del presidente joe biden
indicó que empezará a desplegar un
pequeño número de tropas en europa
oriental
hoy mismo hoy mismo avanzaron las
conversaciones para tres escalar a la
crisis el presidente de francia conversó
con vladimir putin y volodymyr selenski
por separado y volvió a abogar por el
diálogo
el gobierno peruano elevó de 6 mil a 11
mil 900 el número de barriles de crudo
que se virtieron en el mar frente a las
costas del país desde la refinería la
pampilla operada por la petrolera
española repsol el ejecutivo aseguró que
se enfrentan a un escenario sin
precedentes en materia ambiental
argentina logró un acuerdo para
refinanciar la deuda de unos 44 mil
millones de dólares que tiene con el
fondo monetario internacional desde 2018
con lo que evitó entrar en cesación de
pagos aún falta que el pacto sea
aprobado por el congreso
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en eeuu en
medio de la atención que enfrenta a
rusia y ucrania
el presidente joe biden anunció que a
corto plazo enviara un pequeño número de
tropas a europa del este esto el mismo
día en que el secretario de defensa y
hoy de austin alertó que rusia ya tiene
el pie de fuerza suficiente en la
frontera con ucrania para atacar a este
país escuchemos abaire ha decidido
cuando trasladar a las tropas
estadounidenses a europa del este
estaré trasladando tropas
estadounidenses a europa del este en los
países de la otan a corto plazo
entretanto el presidente francés
emmanuel makoun conversó tanto con su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin como con el
mandatario ucraniano volodymyr selenski
putin y macrón acordaron la necesidad de
una desescalada de la crisis con celesc
y el jefe de estado galo enfocó su
charla en la intención de mantener el
avance de los diálogos diplomáticos con
rusia con la mediación de francia y
alemania- manuel acá no nos amplia un
llamado a la calma en medio de la
creciente tensión
el presidente ruso vladimir putin habló
con su homólogo francés emmanuel marco y
negó toda intención de invadir ucrania
sin embargo el mandatario hizo un
reclamo por las respuestas
estadounidenses y de la otan sobre sus
pedidos de seguridad que para el kremlin
no fueron las esperadas en un esfuerzo
por hacer prevalecer la diplomacia marco
también sostuvo una llamada con el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
en la que acordaron seguir impulsando
los diálogos a nivel diplomático con
moscú selenski pidió este viernes evitar
el mayor riesgo de no retener el estado
es la desestabilización dentro de
nuestro estado
esto es una situación vulnerable para
ucrania la ucr en la sensación de los
medios es que tenemos una guerra tenemos
tropas en las carreteras tenemos
movilización la gente se va no es así no
necesitamos este pánico se está un
llamado a bajar el tono que contrasta
con las declaraciones estadounidenses
el pentágono alertó sobre la situación
de la frontera ruso-ucraniana
pero creemos que el presidente putin
haya tomado la decisión final de usar
sus fuerzas contra ucrania está claro
que ahora tiene la capacidad
una eventual escalada militar tendría
impactos directos en el ámbito
energético para europa el presidente
estadounidense joe biden sostuvo un
encuentro con la presidenta de la
comisión europea ursula von der leyen en
la que se comprometieron a cooperar para
asegurar el suministro de gas al viejo
continente ante el temor de una
interrupción del gas ruso hacia europa
en perú las autoridades se elevaron de
6000 a 11.900 la cifra de barriles de
petróleo derramados al mar frente a las
costas del país y aseguraron que se
trata de un escenario ambiental sin
precedentes para la nación suramericana
a su vez el ministro de ambiente rubén
ramírez aseguró que la compañía repsol
encargada de la refinería donde ocurrió
el vertimiento no está realizando las
labores de limpieza que se le asignaron
desde el hima francisco zacarías
corresponsal de france 24 nos dio más
detalles las autoridades peruanas han
actualizado sus cálculos respecto al
volumen de petróleo derramado por repsol
en las costas de lima a unos 11 mil 900
barriles según alfredo mamani
viceministra de ambiente esta cifra es
mucho más que los 6 mil barriles de
crudo como inicialmente había anunciado
la empresa española pero algunos
especialistas señalan que los cálculos
han quedado cortos y en realidad del
crudo vertido al mar bordearía a los
16.000 barriles de petróleo las
autoridades peruanas afirman que esta
nación se encuentra frente a un
escenario sin precedentes en su historia
ambiental hoy la justicia de este país
prohibió por 18 meses las del perú al
ciudadano español jaime fernández y
otros tres funcionarios mientras
continúan las investigaciones los
inculpados deberán afrontar las
indagaciones por el presunto delito de
contaminación ambiental que es
sancionado por las leyes peruanas con
pena privativa de la libertad de hasta
siete años por lo pronto el organismo de
evaluación y fiscalización ambiental
oefa ha impuesto una multa a repsol por
más de cuatro millones de dólares y en
medio de estas diligencias legales una
misión de expertos de la organización de
las naciones unidas afirma que el
derrame de petróleo en el mar y lima
califica como grave según los estándares
internacionales
vamos ahora hasta argentina el gobierno
de alberto fernández logró un acuerdo
con el fondo monetario internacional
para refinanciar los pagos de la deuda
de más de 44 mil millones de dólares que
mantiene desde 2018 el pacto llegó
justamente el día en que buenos aires-
tenía que hacer un pago de 730 millones
de dólares con lo que evitó caer en
cesación de pagos desde la capital
argentina natal yoko soy corresponsal de
france 24 nos amplia en primer lugar una
reacción favorable de los mercados cayó
el riesgo-país que es una suerte de
indicador de cuán cerca puede estar
argentina en este caso de una sensación
de pagos- bueno no entran sensación de
pagos del país con este principio de
acuerdo con este entendimiento con el
fondo monetario internacional también a
nivel local cayó ligeramente el valor
del dólar paralelo del dólar no oficial
que en argentina es leído como una
especie de indicador de la confianza del
propio país de los propios argentinos en
la estabilidad del futuro de la economía
desde la oposición juntos por el cambio
el partido del ex presidente mauricio
macri el partido que cuando estaba en el
gobierno fue el que tomó esta deuda que
está renegociando dijo que ve con buenos
ojos este primer paso y lo estará
siguiendo para conocer los detalles
justamente eso es a lo que se le está
apretando muchísima atención desde todos
lados los detalles específicos la
izquierda ya salió a criticar a decir
que no debería renegociar se de ningún
modo la deuda que no es legítima y que
no se debe pagar desde sectores más
hacia la derecha se cuestionó que el
gobierno no se compromete un déficit
fiscal más rotundo más fuerte y como
decía esperando los detalles que se
conocerán a medida avance las
negociaciones que el voto del fondo de
de lo que ya lo acordado hasta ahora y
que este acuerdo pase por el congreso de
la nación que deberá aprobarlo el
presidente brasileño ya ir bolsonaro no
se presentó a declarar ante la policía
federal con lo que incumplido la orden
de un juez del tribunal supremo que la
investiga por presuntamente difundir
documentos secretos para desacreditar el
sistema electoral faltando 11 minutos
para el horario establecido un abogado
del jefe del estado presentó un recurso
para qué bolsonaro no tuviera que
asistir a la diligencia lo que fue
rechazado por el juez el jurista pidió
que la decisión del juez federal fue ser
revertida o al menos evaluada por el
pleno del tribunal
este viernes el gobierno australiano
anunció que destinará el equivalente a
700 millones de dólares estadounidenses
para la conservación de la gran barrera
de coral el arrecife más grande del
mundo
es el arrecife de coral más grande del
mundo y australia lo quiere salvar
especialmente después de que la unesco
amenazara con incluir a la gran barrera
de coral en la lista de patrimonio
mundial en peligro por su deterioro por
lo que ha anunciado un paquete de ayuda
económica vamos a comprometer esos mil
millones de dólares australianos durante
los próximos nueve años eso se suma a
los dos mil millones que ya hemos
invertido eso es cuidar del arrecife ya
sea por la ciencia ya sea por continuar
con nuestra batalla contra la estrella
de mar de corona de espinas o mejorar la
calidad del agua el ecosistema natural
se ha enfrentado a tres eventos de
blanqueamiento masivo desde 2015 y de
sus trescientos cuarenta y ocho mil
kilómetros cuadrados y 411 especies
distintas de coral tan sólo el 2% de
estos animales han conseguido sortear el
blanqueamiento además la gran barrera ha
perdido el 50 por ciento de sus corales
en las últimas tres décadas un fenómeno
en el que la crisis climática tiene
mucho que ver
en la crisis climática es la mayor
amenaza para la gran barrera de coral
fue un poco chocante que este paquete no
lo mencionar en absoluto entienden es
packers o
los que estamos aquí en primera línea
investigando haciendo ciencia y
trabajando por la conservación de la
gran barrera de coral y de los arrecifes
de todo el mundo estamos bastante
preocupados con el gobierno de morrison
ha rehusado abordar la crisis climática
y apoya a las industrias del carbón y
del gas muy contaminantes no obstante
las encuestas muestran que más del 60
por ciento de la ciudadanía quiere
combatir este fenómeno y así poder
salvar maravillas naturales como la gran
barrera de coral es todo por el momento
a ustedes gracias por su sintonía
volvemos en breve aquí en france 24
[Música]